biggest season is about to begin over at
the smith center we haven't said that in
a couple of years
11 dazzling award-winning productions
going to take center stage they begin in
august christian casadas joining us in
studio tonight with more on the lineup
and which also celebrates the venue's 10
year anniversary ten years can you
believe that huge milestone here for the
smith center now of course they have an
impressive history of broadway shows but
if you haven't been to the venue well
this might be the season to check them
out
we're so happy to be reopened again and
welcome our friends and neighbors back
to the smith center
it's been a long couple of years the
smith center is about to shine even
brighter this year according to its
president myron martin as a lineup
includes a series of popular broadway
productions we have built up a clientele
a group of people
who want to come and see great broadway
shows the prom hades town jagged little
pill
six and hamilton jump start the new
season promising the las vegas community
something for everyone and in fact we
proved that
the smith center was a place that could
bring top shows since then we've had all
the top shows including hamilton i
mentioned it's coming back as holidays
roll in annie to kill a mockingbird
moulin rouge the musical disney's frozen
mean girls and tina the tina turner
musical wraps up the 11 show roster
online fans are not holding back on the
venue's facebook rus says incredible
lineup
the lineup also celebrates the smith
center's 10th anniversary at the hearts
of the arts in downtown las vegas when
we opened 10 years ago it wasn't easy
to get the big blockbuster shows to come
to las vegas after 10 years now the
producers in new york love us
they plan on las vegas being one of
their most important stops on the tours
it's a great lineup all right if you
have season tickets from last year you
can now renew or maybe become a season
ticket holder now the box office isn't
open right now for in-person purchases
so you need to do it online you can find
a link on our website
eightnewsnow.com christian costco is
live local now